why isn't there indeterminacy about
knowing how it got up there in the first
place do you have indetermacy on both
sides what it says is that if you have a
mass that's at the top of a dome and
it's friction listen the Dome is
characterized by a certain curve which
needs to be defined specifically then
it's at rest at the top of the dome but
at any T that's non-negative any time
that's greater than zero it can take off
why is it why why is what you're
describing to me asymmetric at all the
point is that you just set up the system
like that as a thought experiment in
order to just put T equals minus t okay
it's just useful to set up the
experiment okay so in that what is the
okay so fine is interesting thought
experiment I like nobody doesn't like
thought experiments then of what utility
is that to the practicing scientist even
if it is of high interest to the
philosopher it then makes you say hey if
there's a classical system that is
determined that's not the case so we
shouldn't say if that's really true
about the Norton Dome then
we shouldn't say classical physics is
deterministic Right correct okay what
does that change I don't get it it's
fine that's great great result okay uh
so let's think about this in a couple
ways so number one what is physics like
physics is understanding what reality is
so we have to put an asterisk on what
reality is because like who the heck
knows what reality is but physicists are
trying to understand what that is
someone like Tim Maudlin would say hey
which I agree with and I never put in
these words before quantum theory is
never talked about in University as a
physicist you'd learn quantum mechanics
and Quantum field Theory but he would
say a theory tells you what the heck
you're dealing with it talks about
ontology
so there needs to be that component as
well what does it need to be if what
we're doing still works it needs to be
to you the philosopher but to me the
practicing scientist that's building
circuit boards based on a complete
understanding of how quantum physics
works I don't need to know that that
doesn't mean I don't want to know it but
the search for that answer if it
distracts me from other progress I will
make in this physical universe and I am
a practicing scientist that's how I'm
going to choose my paths in that way
so yeah quantum physics who was it that
said the day you understand quantum
physics is the day you can be certain
you don't
because you it's not there are
variations on that our native senses to
to interpret and okay
so that's one view you can just take the
view that hey whatever is useful let me
just build something with it and that's
how I think of physics that's how I
think of physics
is matter of motion and energy and and
every way that allows me to predict the
future of those systems so that I can
exploit it to the benefit of
civilization and and intellectual
Pursuit that's what I think of physics
okay so there's a couple of points there
number one there's a value in there
which isn't derivable from the physical
facts what do you mean a value what do
you mean I like it does you want to do
something that's good you want to do
something useful so you're not just
doing anything no no I didn't say use
did I say useful let me give a different
word
um let me be more precise sure and less
precise at the same time
um I'd like to know ever more about how
the universe works
so that I can invoke it
in the progress of civilization and by
progress I mean
uh new understandings the history of
this exercise often hardly ever doesn't
convert to new inventions new means of
living to prolong our our benefits to
our health our longevity uh and just our
Enlightenment about how the universe
works
so that's that's how I think of physics
and it's the most fundamental level with
chemistry layered on that and then
biology layered on top of that I think
that's an unfair characterization of how
physics developed and even develops to
the state now as for modern examples
okay let's put that aside what makes it
unfair what makes it unfair I'd say I
thought plenty about Mock's principle
and Einstein also thought about other
philosophical positions by the way
Mark's principle was a philosopher from
the 19th the 19th century not so that
that's pre the era that I'm describing
here in terms of the value and influence
of philosophers in the thinking of a
modern physicist who's doing actual
making actual discoveries so so you can
mention Mock and I'll give you a mock
but there's not much after mock that you
can cite yeah but go on John Bell of the
Bells theorems that we just mentioned
are the bell's inequalities of the Nobel
Prize he was influenced yeah but Sean
Bell great question to you
um was he trained as a philosopher or as
a physicist
that's kind of my point here
I think he was trained as a physicist
and so
um
and not not to be pedantic about it but
it's the value of learning how the
physical Universe Works
with Laboratories
okay relative to armchairs that's really
what I'm getting at here but sure it's
great the bell's inequality theorem very
important very thought provoking as any
good philosophical conclusion should be
yeah so I think we're speaking past one
another so let me be precise because I
don't want to get misconstrued what I'm
saying is that physics benefits from an
understanding of philosophy and also it
did especially physical statements by a
physicist have embedded in them
philosophical assumptions so if they say
something about material there's like
materialism is in there what is that
what is a material can we Define it
specifically musings like actually
sitting and thinking about what the heck
exists what is the nature of this what
is space time you mentioned that this is
something we don't talk about much
actually there's several people who
think that space-time is something
that's emergent and so they deeply they
think about well are we on the boundary
are we in the bulk is it discrete is it
not what does that mean is it real does
it have a variable associated with it
like there before we measure it yeah
yeah I got you a characteristic thing
yeah yeah that's all good does our
Consciousness have something to do with
it there's like 30 interpretations of
quantum mechanics maybe four of them
have to do with Consciousness but still
those are all by the way since we
actually really don't understand
Consciousness and the evidence that we
don't understand it is that people keep
writing books on it all right claiming
they know it that's the evidence that we
don't know anything about that to take
Consciousness about which we know very
little to explain something in quantum
physics or to have quantum physics and
understanding a quantifix that nobody
has commingle with Consciousness feels
like very tentative land to stand on
to take two things that are not deeply
understood and use one to explain the
other I I
I'm I'm disturbed when I see people do
that not this that overstates it I'm I'm
intrigued that people have the urge to
do it
but I've make sure I do not ever have
the urge to explain something I don't
understand but something else I don't
understand I I don't think that's the
wisest path to be on it's a fun path
like over beer sure
but to commit your life to it I I don't
I don't know I would question that
relative to having applying that same
brain power in other ways now you
mentioned other things like uh
materialism okay
um
that of course physics modern science
especially Western science is highly
materialistic I mean it's in fact almost
entirely materialistic I don't know any
other
uh I don't think there's any dimension
of spiritualism if we take that as the
opposite of materialism I don't know any
dimension of spirit spiritualism in
traditional Western science
so
you said how do we Define
materialism is that a problem how to
define that is this a challenge
is this really something people are
distracted by
I wouldn't put the term distracted with
anything that's a Philosophical
Investigation because of reasons like I
mentioned before a physicists
are steeped in philosophy even if they
don't know it and this is a point Carlo
ravelli Lee smullen I'm sure you know
them I met Lee and I know Lee and I only
know of course of uh rovelli's books
Carlo rivelli and Lee smolin as well as
this guy named abay ashtakar are the
founders of Luke quantum gravity this is
also something that abayashtakar says he
makes a great analogy so if you have a
spear you have to cover it with two open
sets you can't just cover it with one
otherwise you distort it so what if
reality is like that where you need
multiple covers and the physical world
the material world is just one of these
open sets but it doesn't cover
everything interesting there's an
internal world and it doesn't have to be
spiritual like well you can call
spiritual something associated yes it's
just a different world it's different
you just just call it different right
very cool it could just be different
whatever that different is yes yes and
he would say that he has investigated
some of that via his inner world he
calls one the inner versus the outer I
love it I don't know if it's as simple
as there are two maybe there's a
plethora anyhow no I love it but of
course uh rovelli and and
um Lisa Mullen have degrees in physics
Okay so
um most of the philosophers of physics
are trained in physics if you enjoyed
that clip then the full podcast is out
right now you can click around here as
well as subscribe to get notified enjoy